[Music]
[Applause]
yes happy Tuesday everybody ah it's good
to be back so last night after all the
campaigning and spending Ron Nikki and
VI run the receiving end of yet another
Trump thumping the three finishing
second third and fourth just like women
at a women's swim meet
cuz the dude always wins they join a
long list of trump thumpies remember the
big stage back in 2015 what a photo
that's like Justin Timberlake with the
rest of in
sync in the end Trump bumped each of
them off like it was the last Act of
Good Fellas those weren't debates they
were crime scenes there were there
should be yellow crime tape around each
of their podiums
good thing Christy was already gone
before Iowa you know how much chalk it
takes to outline that
body you shouldn't laugh at that he's
struggling so last night it wasn't
really a caucus it was a
carcass I guess prila predicted it right
let's talk about the fact that President
Trump incited an
erection and last night he did so what
does last night's result mean for
November well while everyone has an
opinion we can't be sure because let's
face it there are only four people in
America who really know what a caucus is
and three of them are Carl
Rove and KLA thinks a caucus is a plant
with pointy stuff on
it but still it looks like the Trump
train has just blasted out of the
station not even Pete Budaj can derail
it but since we since we all knew that
this would happen despite the other
candidate spending a combined 250
million bucks campaigning was it all
really necessary think about that 250
mil for an election the Republicans knew
would turn out this way with Trump way
out on top that's a lot of money to
waste when you could invest it in a
couple of 100 Biden
paintings point is uh for the sake of
chasing an illusion couldn't that money
have been directed elsewhere like maybe
at the guy the Republicans are trying to
beat in
November no not Michelle
Obama who put that in there here's what
pisses me off okay we're told this
caucus is necessary even though we knew
Trump was going to win big and all the
hundreds of millions spent would be
wasted and what happens they called it
in 30 minutes the reasoning is it's a
blowout so why wait wow that's exactly
the same reason for ignoring the caucus
except now they just wasted Millions to
to prove that point that's a ton of
money that could be used to fight Biden
but spent on a foregone conclusion look
Trump is less than perfect who isn't
he's got baggage but remember most of
that baggage is put there by the Dems
and he does make it easy for him for
them but they do the same to every
Republican nominee no matter who it is
and with every poll showing a margin
between Trump and his Rivals that's
wider than the gaps in Jesse waters's
resume
you got to ask was this money well
spent it's
true when every metric shows the country
is going in the wrong direction and the
Dam's gearing up to spend the GNP of
Brazil to keep Mr Magoo's finger on the
button and by the button I mean His Life
Alert I'm thinking whatever the
Challenger spent that cash on was in the
wrong places help budl light's marketing
team spent money more wisely meanwhile
the Trump train ran over more than the
other candidates it also barreled
straight over the collective psyche of
the Lefty media who right now appear
about as stable as Gerald Nadler
juggling three rotisserie chickens on a
unicycle Trump has in some ways become
religion for a certain section of the
American electorate and especially for
evangelicals this is a state that is
over represent over represented by white
Christians we can all sit here and put
on sackcloth and Ashes and and and moan
about Donald Trump getting 51% of the
vote got to say for people who actually
want to win general elections that's not
good news there is an authoritarian
movement inside Republican politics that
isn't being Bamboozled by Trump they are
pushing Trump to get more and more
extreme it's good to see Tony da is
still working
look and he passed away I believe anyway
still kind of funny though but Rachel I
am so sorry this happened to you but can
I suggest something maybe pace yourself
it's going to be a long election and we
all knew what the outcome would be but
you're already melting down like a
Hershey bar in Anna Navarro's
armpit but of all the media takes here's
my favorite from Dick Morris remember
that fella watch closely
well I think Trump is going to score a
huge Victory I think the media is going
to try to downplay it because as you
correctly said they're basically
supporting um uh they're basically
supporting Nikki
haey not the
greatest I mean who knew Dick Morris
lives at the
YMCA Hard Times Hard Times my
friend I don't I can't even continue of
course Dan santis and Nikki Haley are
still in the race and they're receiving
donations the hope is that the clear
front runner will somehow crash and burn
the hope that lightning strikes or if
Chris Christie cuts his brake lines yeah
like he could fit under a
car and for Biden it would be when they
finally admit the obvious and take him
off solid
food some Dems who live in the real
world have labeled Biden DNR do not
reelect and while Ron and Nikki hover
about V is looking like the smart one he
knew how this would go so he took a shot
raised his profile and when the right
time came suspended his campaign if
Trump wins you could bet he's looking at
a big spot maybe Secretary of
foreheads but it's not bad for a guy Joe
Biden thinks should be running a
7-Eleven so now we're left with the
clear winner and two others praying that
the m guy gets taken out which is sort
of like things around here on this
show look I get it this is our process
and whoever set it up it's what we've
got and no system is perfect but there's
no denying that Iowa was like betting on
the University of Michigan versus the St
Jude
Allstars betting Millions on
it all for a mirage that never trumpers
in the media left hoped would be
real
and it's on to New Hampshire the Live
Free or vote Biden state where we'll be
told Nikki is within Striking Distance
and Ronda santis is The Comeback Kid and
more Millions spent by The Hope for
disaster candidates and their supporters
but as the saying goes hope is not a
method and the truth is we're almost
certainly headed for a 2020 rematch and
the sooner we accept it the better and
personally I like Trump's chances
against this
guy
it's kind of sad the Dems are hoping
Trump won't make it to November while
praying Joe makes it past
Wednesday here he
is let's welcome tonight's guest if I'm
the poor man's Dennis Miller that he's
the rich man's Greg Gutfeld comedian and
in activist Dennis
Miller she's like a downed power line
full of energy but will kill you if you
touch her host of the fox True Crime
podcast Emily
compano his Bakers Dozen refers to his
monthly body count former CIA operative
and host of the president's Daily Brief
podcast Mike
Baker
and finally she attracts old more old
white men than the Iowa caucus New York
Times bestselling author and Fox News
contributor cat
Tim Dennis Miller welcome to this show
thanks for having me my pleasure I like
that when you looked over here and you
said hey I didn't know you sat well
listen I I've known you for years and I
I've been on your other shows it's just
I the last couple years I've been living
as a resident expat I don't pay as much
attention as I used to because uh I
don't know it's just the frustrating
times in an odd way but I I did not I uh
I've seen you many shows but I didn't
know of this one oh that's okay what how
did you feel about the outcome of last
night were you surprised anything
interesting or catch your eye well you
know as I said I am not following as
closely but I do know this if Trump runs
through this time in the exact same
manner he did last time
he's missing a huge opportunity he
always Prides himself on saying never
apologize people are looking for some
sort of sign from him if I was him I'd
come out somewhere soon and I would say
listen I've been under an insane amount
of pressure for a lot of years now when
you mix it in with my uh Vol innate
volatility and the fact that I haven't
played politics my whole life I've made
some mistakes and I've been a little
rough with certain people and I just
wanted to come out tonight and say uh I
think the country's in trouble and I'm
willing to violate one of my Cardinal
laws and say I'm sorry when I've missed
the point I think a lot of people out
there would just say because even the
people who like Trump and you know that
I think they think first off by the way
he also when he goes to the middle of
the country and stands in front of all
these local functionaries uh in Iowa for
instance he should demand that the day
before he gets there they get a spray T
because he's standing out there looking
like an old brown wallet I've lost and
there behind him it's like Saddles shoes
or something he had to like try to melt
in a little but if I was him I would
just ex that would blow people's mind
little not even that say the words uh I
apologize you know how he always has
prided himself I apologize when I've
missed the point I think there's a lot
of people the hard zealots who would not
like that I think there's many more
people in that middle pool think the
country's
you what you're saying is like he all he
needs to do is kind of give them a
reason to vote for them and it that
could be it that could be the one well
listen Biden at this point let's face
facts he thinks bottled water tastes
better if you shake it real hard so he's
a you know
he's there's a lot of people don't want
to go down that road but Trump doesn't
afford them any breathing space even
this if you said this to him he that's B
I'll never he just okay I get it but at
some point like a character in a movie
you want to see an arc his Arc right now
would be to say I've made some mistakes
I'm sorry there's a there's more chance
of of of a monkey riding a unicorn
flying out of my ass then but that
happened last year I like I like your
thought that did happen last year yeah I
don't know how you did that I know well
I got it fixed why don't you bring an
answer I'm tired of your I think
what get it together man you're on
television yeah I can get this at home
you
know
so I uh I I think what he should do is I
think he should
apologize oh no that's already
been I'm sorry I I don't have an
original thought on this
one did you watch last night Mikey did
you watch last night did I watch last
night I am the host of the country's
fastest growing News podcast the
president's Daily Brief I am obligated
to watch things like this anything
strike your interest the so
no uh no I did this time around
um you know what the one thing that that
struck me is that the the only uh person
probably happier about the result and
and that massive margin of Victory uh
than Trump was uh the uh Democratic
strategist because they are building
their entire plan their battle plan for
the next several months around Trump and
around the idea and and it's not even
just Maga deplorables anymore they are
already moving the narrative to say it's
every Republican it's it's Trump and
anyone who vot votes for him regardless
of where they may actually sit on the
political spectrum and and whether they
like the policies and they don't like
Trump whatever they're just throwing
everybody in that basket now yeah what
struck me is now a stadium Emily Emily
what a lovely color tonight thanks yeah
I'm talking about my sweater I I was
like never say anything
nice it's always a trick yeah I know you
fell for it again comp what uh what what
did you gain from last night any wisdom
I don't know about wisdom but what I
what struck me was the disparity as
always between what Iowan said and what
the mainstream liberal media how they
characterized what they said so we know
that coming out of that historical vote
that people found that immigration was
the most important issue and among the
top issues for those that it wasn't
Paramount and that was characterized by
this left-wing media as being about skin
color they said it was about racism they
said it was about a negative view of
America First in the lake they have been
painting the bottom of their screens
with all of these people leaving the
polls or leaving you know in the exit
polls said that they didn't believe
Biden actually won the election and that
it wouldn't matter if Donald Trump was
convicted they are shoving these voters
into the same boxes that they want them
to reside in but the overwhelming 82% of
those Iowans that voted for Trump they
voted for him the number one reason
because he would fight for people like
me MH and the difference between how
this Administration views Americans and
how the left-wing media views Americans
is that the like me is whatever box they
shove them in when the reality is you
can't paint the same brush as every
single voter for Trump it's every
American it's every skin color it's
everyone who is sick and tired of being
told what to do and how to cook and how
to drive and what to drive and what
their money has to go toward and what to
educate their kids on it's everybody
that is sick and tired of being told day
in and day out that they can think
better for us so keep it up though
Democrats because you are going to get
trounced in the national election I
can't wait
cat see how they applaud when I go to
you
yeah you should learn something about
you should learn from that Emily they
ploted when I went to cat what are your
thoughts here close out this seg no I'm
still thinking about the underwear guy
let's talk okay let's talk about let's
talk about there so many things there's
so many things because he walked in and
Dick Mo he didn't react which means he
knows this guy okay he knows very well
and he's so confident when he walks in
he doesn't even stop right and like I
get that he has a he he like if I ever
get a boob job I will show him that
picture that guy had a great set on him
but he was so confident sometimes if if
you know my husband's on a zoom call I'm
like I'm so s right and this guy's on TV
just walks through nobody reacts I mean
come on you got to say I can't help but
notice sir that a man in underwear with
giant boobs just walked by your shop all
right okay I spent almost all day
Googling for information I found nothing
do you think okay do you think this was
uh uh somebody's house adjoining hotel
rooms some kind of swingers convention
because he doesn't react an underwear
man acts as if he's supposed to be doing
that like why wouldn't I be doing that
why would I have a shirt on why would I
have pants on why wouldn't I walk and
how many so many guys don't wear white
beaters anymore and this is the perfect
way I think dick was doing a table read
for Marty at the Kenley
players that guy who just came in is has
the Borg M that's true that's I can walk
into any room as confidently as he did
that I would be so much further in life
and so many people don't call them wife
beaters anymore either oh what do they
call them now uh uh tank tops tank tops
tank tops yes no I know that's true
please if anybody knows this man I want
tell me what happened I we need to get
him on this show immediately all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else